joe biden and democrats better think
twice about unleashing the green new
deal on the whole country
just take a look at what's happening in
texas the state hit with massive power
outages
from a giant winter storm that's
hammering most of the country
four million people in the state are in
the dark and don't have heat
the cold crippling texas power grid and
part of the reason why
is because wind turbines are frozen
half of the state's wind power capacity
was reportedly offline
former energy secretary rick perry says
what's happening in his home state could
be
a sign of things to come if this green
new deal goes forward the way that the
biden administration appears to want it
to
then we'll have more events like we've
had in texas all across the country
as we strangle the diversity that we're
going to need to keep this country going
and keep this country economically
powerful
and the wall street journal editorial
board summing things up this way
quote herein is the paradox of the
left's climate agenda
the less we use fossil fuels the more we
need them
the byte administration's plan to banish
fossil fuels
is a greater existential threat to
americans
than climate change all right dana i
know you read that editorial it's six
o'clock this morning and it makes a
great point you have to have
coal you have to have nuclear as backup
in the mix
when something like this goes down it's
a tragic situation 15 people have lost
their lives and that's just so far when
you don't have heat
and you don't have any electricity in
the middle of a winter snap like a cold
snap like this it's terrifying
claire mccaskill the former senator of
missouri she
tweeted texans mocking them saying stay
home to stay safe
and she was making fun of them basically
because that was what she thinks that a
lot of people
in texas did not do during covid um to
me this is not funny
um it's very troubling to look at what
the future could bring so biden's
climate agenda jesse
says that by 2035 we'd have 100
renewable energy like i can actually see
2035 from my house like it's not that
far from here
i talked to a guy named dan turner over
at power of the future just a couple of
things to note
in 2009 coal-fired power plants
generated nearly 37 percent of the texas
electricity
wind was 6 percent since then since 2009
three texas coal-fired power plants have
closed wind power has
more than quadrupled as the you know
transmissions lines from that wind got
into the urban areas
but the in the same period energy
consumption rose by 20 percent
because you have all these people that
want to move to texas because it's a
better lifestyle right how many people
we've shown you how much it costs to get
a one-way u-haul
kennedy must not like that answer uh to
get one to get a one-way u-haul from
california to texas
kennedy's truck was powered by wind
turbine i'm sorry about that kenneth
well and jesse last night did you see
what happened when rick perry was on
with tucker carlson
his pa the power went out and tucker
said okay you're proving my point like
as
we said here i am for all sorts of
different types of energy mixes
i like solar great yeah wind great like
have all of it but the thing is is that
the wind doesn't always blow the sun
doesn't always shine
coal will burn um we're working on ways
to do it more cleanly but we're not
going to get to 20 to 100
renewable by 2035. fingers crossed for
good weather is not a sound policy
i agree with that and you mentioned
claire mccaskill greg
i think someone else on mbc news said
something pretty dopey about what's
going on down in texas
let's roll the tape of chuck todd
the only upside here is i assume the
cold weather motivates people to wear a
mask because it's one extra layer
on your face
okay greg he needs like he needs four
layers on his face
four bags around his face that was
stupid
uh people say stupid things i have said
stupid things um
but this is actually
a reality check the problem is when it
comes to green energy
the people that advocate for it they
don't like reality
you know windmills and solar are backup
singers they aren't the lead singer
gas and coal that's tony orlando
windmills and solar
that's dawn ironically the backup
singers
also need backup singers and that's the
curse of intermittent fuels
they're intermittent which means they
flunk the single most important test
of fuel sources reliability so
if you just look if you change the way
you look at windmills
you will actually like them windmills
are not fuel sources
they are fuel savers so if they only
generate one percent capacity you know
of the capacity which is
tiny which has happened in england and
in germany just one percent
at least you can say well hey that's
we're saving one percent of our coal
right but when you look at these massive
farms it's not worth it i think the
answer
is in front of our face and we know this
it's nuclear energy
it's clean it's safe the dams even
for greenpeace uh former leaders of
greenpeace and
and other uh environmental groups are
admitting that they were wrong
sadly the entertainment industry of the
1970s pretty much
uh dictated our energy policy and we're
still battling our way out of that
kennedy it looks like the people that
installed the wind turbines in texas
they didn't pay that extra two grand to
install the de-icing technology
that they have this de-icing technology
and other windmills all over the country
but
they were a little cheap down there in
the wind guys with texas and
and it's now costing lives that's
absolutely right and
we have to ask ourselves what kind of a
country do we want to live in and what
are we
willing to sacrifice in the name of the
climate cult
everyone wants a cleaner planet everyone
wants cleaner energy but i don't think
there's been a thorough investigation
to greg's point about really finding new
technologies the private sector is going
to do that
but greg's actually absolutely right
about nuclear and thorium
and there are ways of producing an
abundance
of clean energy which they do around the
world
where they don't have access to natural
gas pipelines like they do
in texas but if you force a a green
economy too quickly
you are going to sacrifice your economy
and you're no longer going to be living
in a first world country
you're going to be living in a third
world country where it is very common in
places like venezuela and zimbabwe to
have
intermittent blackouts but guess what
it's no way to live and when it's cold
and people can't go anywhere they're
already immobile and vulnerable they are
going to die
and if you send them to shelters then
they are going to catch covet and they
are going to die
so it is very very inhumane and
shame on the state government for not
having better foresight not only for a
particular storm
but the consequences of this sort of
green energy
yeah and our hearts go out to all the
people in texas suffering
right now all right juan tell us how
this is all trump's fault
well let me just introduce a different
fact pattern for you jessie
uh because i was reading today where dan
woodfin who's the senior director of the
electric reliability council of texas
they run the texas power grid which is
by the way different
than most of the country it is just in
texas they don't relate to the national
power grid they can't borrow power
anyway mr woodfin said this natural gas
and coal
are 60 of texas energy nuclear energy
another 11
so that's like 70 percent wind is less
than a quarter
so what he says was that when you see
this failure that we're experiencing in
texas now it's because
gas coal generators
froze up in the midst of this coal snap
that's the big problem not what's going
on with anybody's wind turbine
so i think that when we politicize this
and make it an attack but they froze on
alternative energy sources why don't we
make this an attack on
alternate energy sources you have to
stop and say oh are we going to say
don't use coal don't use gas don't use
nuclear because
some of those generators froze we
wouldn't say that we'd say there was a
problem
and we'd ask our politicians to do a
better job of preparing for
a cold weather snap in texas when most
of these generators are
oriented to deal with higher electrical
demand
from you know air conditioners during
the summer months
but what we're seeing now i think is
sort of misdirection and political
finger pointing by
politicians like governor abbott but it
doesn't fit the facts the facts are the
gold
the coal and gas are the ones who failed
in this emergency okay
so the all the video that we've seen of
the frozen wind turbines that's just
that's fake news one
it's only it's only three those are
spinning right now
they might have okay i repeat they're
only 11
so 60 coal and gas that's the problem
that has people in the dark and cold
okay up next the cuomo cover-ups